cas ce soir c'est bien je suis là
parfait alors j'ai prévenu de montréal
aujourd'hui je suis venue de
saint-etienne c'est un peu moins
exotique désolant vous raconter des
choses mais bravo effectivement voilà on
se raconter des choses j'étais aux
émirats j'étais si j'étais ça c'est vrai
tout çà c'est vrai mais ce soir je suis
pas venu de là bas par contre je vous
apporte une vision un petit peu
différente de ce que vous avez pu avoir
ce soir concernant les mondialisation
qui est issu cette vision là de mon
expérience internationale
d'ailleurs j'ai du mal à qualifier
c'était un peu le sujet de ce soir
puisqu'on parle de globo mindset alors
pourquoi je parle de globalsign 7 ce
soir parce que pendant des années moi
qui n'ai pas grandi en france je parlais
d'abord allemand avant de parler
français
je rêvais en france beaucoup plus tard
j'ai fait une carrière internationale
dans le domaine de l'intelligence
économique qui m'a poussé rencontré
beaucoup de monde pour trouver plein
d'informations parler dans différentes
langues et m'insérer dans différents
milieux pour pouvoir justement répondre
aux besoins de lobbying précisément et
oui j'étais de ce côté-là et également
les besoins deux lignes de mes clients
et les besoins également d'informations
d'institutions internationales et de
d'information financier a pour des
clients dans le domaine de la banque
alors à un moment je dois vous avouer je
ne savais plus trop où j'en étais c'est
à dire quelle était ma compétence
qu'elle était exactement mon identité
puisque j'étais en allemagne j'étais
français en france quand je passais je
parle avec un accent allemand
j'ai fait une partie de mon lycée en
turquie donc là j'étais le franco-turc
que mélanger après je suis parti
également moyen-orient où la gt le
français qui avait vécu en turquie où le
français qui parlait très bien turc
enfin je me retrouvais vraiment plu du
tout professionnellement c'est pareil
est ce que vous dites à quelqu'un quand
vous revenez après 20 ans comme j'ai
fait l'année dernière
vous dites j'ai fait l'intelligence
économique au moyen-orient j'avais mon
bureau race a dream à j'ai travaillé à
karachi et j'ai continué à pékin on vous
regarde avec des yeux comme n'est pas
possible et je suis diplômé de mcgill à
montréal
donc c'est absolument invraisemblable
alors comment je pouvais me définir moi
j'ai beaucoup de concepts
j'ai essayé de m'identifier un petit peu
à ce qui existait dans la littérature
globalisante on va dire dans le globish
généralisée
j'ai toujours eu la tendance à fuir les
besoins world
1 les mots à la mode parce que en fait
il recouvre beaucoup d'identité beaucoup
de notions qui ne font pas sens parce qu
elles ne s'appuient pas sur des réalités
et bien pourtant j'en ai trouvé un qui
semblait correspondre un peu à ce que
moi j'arrivais à définir comme identité
pour mon expérience et pour mon parcours
de vire c'est le terme de globo mindset
alors qu'est ce que c'est globo mindset
très difficile à traduire en français
dans cette introduction que j'ai pu lire
en français en français français pas de
cas pas du canada pas québécois
donc certains disent que c'est une
mentalité internationale ok bon pourquoi
pas d'autres disent ils mentalité
globalhort ça veut peut rien dire parce
que globale en france on sait pas trop
ce que ça veut dire
donc en fait on va essayer de définir de
façon un peu différente c'est un peu
l'objectif de ma présence ici un globule
marines est pour moi et que moi je le
définis par mon expérience
ce n'est pas par exemple on va prendre
définition négative ce n'est pas être
citoyen du monde
pendant des années on m'a qualifié de
citoyens du monde parce que j'étais en
turquie lendemain j'étais au pakistan le
lendemain j'étais en irak fin bon voilà
donc en gros j'étais jamais nulle part
mais toujours partout alors citoyens du
monde ok bon je me gargariser de ça
c'est génial de cette fin du monde on
est partout chez soi on a toujours des
gens des amis partout un peu comme les
marins dans lesquels dans les vieilles
comptines pour enfants
vraiment c'était très valorisant pour
moi j'étais en fait libre de tout un peu
supérieur à tout le monde aussi je
précise quand même ça je suis toujours
mais bon ça c'est moins évident donc si
vous voulez on me l'a dit en plusieurs
langues de l'omelette vie en turquie n'y
a pas de tentation
on me l'a dit en anglais ces 19 the
world et puis d'autres langues je peux à
tout les faire parce que ça fait un peu
long surtout que je parle pas tout en
plus donc à ce concept ne m'allait pas
parce qu'en fait quand on parle de
citoyens du monde dans la mondialisation
actuelle ça sous-entend l'idée que vous
n'avez plus de culture que les gens en
face non pas et qu'on est tous les
joyeux consommateurs de café avec des
sirènes dessus ou de d'autres marques
internationales qui vous anime votre
identité et l'identité des autres c'est
ce qu'on aimerait pouvoir dire c'est ce
que le marketing international
souhaiterais vous
dran c'est vrai qu'on soit tous pareils
commence tout les mêmes choses de pékin
à shanghai en passant par karachi en
passant par washington et c'est
malheureusement c'est pas la réalité
c'est pas cette réalité à laquelle moi
j'avais cru mais c'est pas cette réalité
à laquelle moi j'ai été confronté parce
que dans le travail que j'ai fait j'ai
dû parler à tout le monde
quand j'ai tout le monde ça allait du
vendeur de thé jusqu'au pdg d'une grande
banque dans différents pays et dans ces
différentes zones je me suis rendu
compte que le rêve de marketing
international qu'on m'avait vendu celui
sur lequel j'avais fait tout mais
l'espoir qu'ils m'avaient vraiment porté
citoyens du monde sa porte tellement
loin ça et bien en fait n'était pas la
réalité est que la réalité était bien
plus complexe peut-être beaucoup plus
dur en même temps beaucoup plus
intéressante et donc c'est cette réalité
là que moi j'ai essayé de réfléchir donc
le guggenheim sept mois correspond dans
mon identité à une façon de pouvoir
s'accaparer la mondialisation en
agissant dessus de façon totalement
positive c'est-à-dire positif pour vous
bien entendu on n'est pas là dans save
the planet of the world qui sont des
choses très très bien je vous rassure je
suis pour sauver la planète moi aussi
mais quand on parle au niveau individuel
parce que pour l'instant se définit tous
comme les identités
quand on se positionne il faut avoir un
concept qu'ils soient opérationnels et
pas juste un mot qu'ils soient complexes
alors global mindset c'est vraiment pour
moi ce qu'on appellerait dans le
l'anglais ou le français de montréal du
empowerment donc la capacité d'acquérir
une volonté et une action sur ce qu'on
fait dans la mondialisation
alors ça saadiens également l'histoire
récente du vin fin du xxème siècle et
début du 21e en même temps c'est un peu
mon histoire là c'est le mur de berlin
en 1989 avec la porte de brandebourg
c'est là où j'ai grandi en fait voilà
moi j'ai grandi pas très loin de là bas
dans le mur enfin pas dans le mur
effectivement directement mais j'étais
entouré par le mur à berlin ouest on
pouvait pas trop sortir je passais de
l'est à l'ouest régulièrement
donc pour moi jusqu'à bas 89 quand
j'étais plus ou moins tout le temps là
bas eh bien le monde était simple il y
avait les gentils mon côté les méchants
de l'autre côté du mur
je n'ai pas dit que les côtés gt1 voilà
mais bon alors c'était très simple et
donc j'avais moi des certitudes sur un
univers extrêmement sainte-claire
confortable finalement même s'il était
un petit peu terrifiant ces histoires de
bombes nucléaires d'arsenal nucléaire
d'invasion de l'armée rouge de l'autre
côté enfin bon on s'y josem enfin
c'était quand même assez confortable
faut bien l'avouer après les ambitions
internationales y en avait pas puisqu'on
était chacun d'un côté du mur c'était
aussi simple que ça alors mon univers
c'est évidemment effondrée ce jour là
mais totalement littéralement effondrée
parce que évidemment tout ce que moi
j'avais pensé avoir vu comme enfants
étant une réalité intangible de
l'humanité
le mur de berlin s'effondre en une nuit
donc moi j'étais encore un peu plus
jeune je vous rassure je ne suis pas si
vieux que ça mais quand même assez vieux
pour me rendre compte il s'est passé à
chose suivante c'est que devant cet
effondrement là moi j'ai eu cette envie
c'est que je vous ai parlé de pouvoir
voyager partout je pouvais voyager avant
mais c'était comme beaucoup plus
compliqué de pouvoir me déplacer dans le
monde entier pouvoir avoir cette soif de
découverte que je vous ai un peu
décrites et qui m'a mois alimentée pour
m'adapter aux clichés du citoyen du
monde
sans trop réfléchir aux conséquences le
problème c'est que le monde qu'on a
célébré comme étant beaucoup plus
ouverts après 89 après l'ouverture la
chute de l'union soviétique et toutes
les conséquences
on s'aperçoit maintenant 2019 trente ans
plus tard
oui je cet âge-là je sais trente ans
plus tard que c'est pas forcément un
monde plus ouvert
c'est un monde où la technologie a
progressé les moyens de communication
les moyens de voyager ont progressé en
termes d'ouverture si elles existent
l'ouverture d'un point du frontalier
elle n'est pas traduite dans les esprits
et ça quand vous faites du travail
international ont fait des relations
internationales au niveau le plus micro
possible que ce soit vous en tant que
chef d'entreprise ou vous négociez avec
des états ou pour le compte de grandes
institutions internationales privées ou
publiques
vous vous en rendez compte moi mon
expérience c'est que le monde a rarement
été aussi divisés
moi j'ai pu le voir depuis 1989 division
elles sont multiples la multiplicité des
réseaux sociaux a encouragé la diffuse
lyon de façon ultra massif des préjugés
on n'est pas dans un monde beaucoup plus
ouvert et la question qu'on doit se
poser actuellement c'est comment en tant
qu'individu en tant que professionnel en
tant que personnes un responsable et
porteurs de projets comment en tant que
chef de famille
on positionne son identité et celle de
ses enfants dans un monde qui bien que
multiples multiplie les barrières de
façon plus ou moins directe et ça c'est
vraiment un enjeu primordial auquel je
vous invite tous à réfléchir
alors il n'y a pas de solution mauvaise
nouvelle je vais pas vous apporter la
lune ce soir j'aurais bien aimé je ne
peux pas il n'y a pas de solution par
contre il ya des pistes de réflexion et
nous sommes pas les seuls à les avoir
envisagé alors ce n'est pas moi je vous
précise tout de suite j'ai passé du
temps aux émirats mais je ne sais pas
moi ça c'est quelqu'un qui est ma source
d'inspiration et que je vous encourage à
explorer si vous ne connaissez pas c'est
sûr wilfred 16 eager qui était un espion
et oui un espion britannique qui est
moins connu que lawrence d'arabie mais
qui était bien plus efficace c'est pour
ça qu'il est moins connu d'ailleurs il
était en fait poster aux émirats arabes
unis est également en arabie saoudite
avant que ça devienne des états enfin en
tout cas les émirats indépendant dans
les années trente à quarante et donc il
a entrepris des expéditions est ce qu'il
est et arabisant des expéditions dans
leurs robes à lille qui est donc le plus
grand désert de dunes du monde qui fait
jeu qui jouxte arabie saoudite et les
pays voisins étant les émirats arabes
unis c'est dans ce cadre là en fait
qu'il a voyagé qui l'a découvert
énormément de choses sur la culture
locale au delà des clichés aux
colonialistes ou néo colonialiste selon
la période qui pouvaient exister
il a engagé une vraie démarche d'amitié
avec les populations locales y compris
dans leur confie qualité entre elles
j'aimerais justement vous lire cet
enseignement qui nous a fait passer dans
un efi s'appelle arabian says je vous
encourage à lire en anglais en français
n'importe quelle langue
vous pouvez le trouver si vous allez aux
émirats je vous conseille de visiter le
musée dali ou il ya un musée donc que
laisse des émirats qui est dédié à sa
présence puisqu'il a contribué
à l'idée de l'émergence des émirats
avant que ce fût ce au possible
je vous lire et je vais commenter après
donc là il parle du jour il va commencer
son expédition avec des bédouins pour
traverser le désert
j'étais leur compagnon de route et il se
serait battu pour me défendre
même contre leur propre frère et il en
attendait d'eux mêmes de ma part mais je
savais que les preuves véritables serait
de vivre avec eux en harmonie et de ne
pas me laisser gagner par l'impatience
me replier sur moi même ou même de
devenir critique vis-à-vis de mode de
vie différent du mien je pense que cette
citation est tirée d'un des chapitres de
son livre est plein d'enseignements pour
nous parce que c'est précisément
l'opposé de ce que nous sommes en train
de vivre à l'époque d'instagram ou de
youtube dont nous profitons ce soir
également
malheureusement notre génération celle
qui viennent n'ont pas forcément cette
éducation sur la façon de diffuser ces
valeurs là de tolérance
il ne s'agit pas de tolérer il s'agit
simplement de se connaître et de
respecter ce qui se passe en face de soi
sans vouloir juger et sans vouloir se
mêler donc un des aspects les plus
importants
vous pouvez développer si vous
travaillez dans le domaine des relations
internationales actuellement au delà des
compétences linguistiques de vos
savoir-faire sur l'économie de données
macro économiques géographiques bourg
vous avez google pour ça ça va vous
aider mais la vraie compétence qu'on
pouvait développer c'est regarder le
monde
c'est ce que font les artistes bah oui
regardez le monde
regardez le monde comment regarder le
monde de façon active sans juger mais de
façon objective ne pas regarder le monde
tel qu'on voudrait qu'il soit positif ou
négatif
regarder le monde avec humilité et
curiosité
c'est dans ce cadre là que vous
arriverez à nouer des vraies relations
et à vous débarrasser des préjugés dont
vous n'avez même pas conscience vous
remarquerez également que vous n'êtes
pas vous les seuls à avoir des préjugés
individuel les autres en ont sur vous
aussi et vous devez accepter dans
certains cas que ces préjugés vous
impact
vous n'êtes pas immunisés ni dans un
sens ni dans l'autre mais pour ça pour
ne pas souffrir de ça et pour pouvoir
faire avancer les dialogues avec les
gens vous rencontrent dans le monde
entier
il faut savoir regarder en toute
simplicité
alors à sa demande de la discipline lors
salle rigolo comme ça en voyage on peut
faire plein de choses
alors vous ne deviendrez pas un global
mind cette heure ci uniquement vous
comptez le nombre de mal ce que vous
avez sur vos cartes gold de compagnie
aérienne va lire tous les langes du
monde
c'est génial hein j'adore ça moi s'il
n'y a pas de problème ça fait pas de
vous un global mindset heures efficace
un très bon voyageur un excellent client
compagnies aériennes ça c'est sûr par
contre il va falloir que vous ayez un
peu d'auto discipline aussi et c'est
très difficile je sais j'ai tellement
fait d'erreur moi même aussi vraiment
j'en ai fait tellement je vous parle en
connaissance de cause je vous en titre
et une après donc il faut simplement
déjà quand on peut le monsieur fait ça
sur la main c'est parce qu'en fait il
faut savoir qu on parle quand on
travaille dans des domaines
internationaux sur des domaines
complexes on ne comprend pas tout il
faut être capable de regarder les
informations dont on dispose et celle
dont on dispose pas et agir en
connaissance de cause sans extrapoler
c'est très difficile parce que nous
avons nos préjugés
je vous donne un exemple j'ai fait une
erreur assez grave qui a fait ce que
coûtait ma vie j'étais donc au sud
soudan pour aller faire une mission de
reconnaissance sur un site industriel
enfin en friche ans parce que c'était la
guerre civile entre deux villes il y
avait une deux ethnies
après l'indépendance du sud soudan qui
se battaient sur des territoires pour
récupérer les territoires agricoles et
je suis passé en fait avec sans faire
attention aux différences locales parce
que j'étais pressé parce que je pense de
toute façon tu ma mission était très
importante et que j'étais très important
j'ai tellement fait ça servait à rien et
du coup j'ai pris comme comme traducteur
et comment comme assistant pour cette
mission là quelqu'un de très bien qu'ils
étaient d'une ethniques étaient en
opposition avec technique sur lequel le
territoire
et est source de conflits on s'est fait
arrêter donc dans la brousse avec des
jantes audi avec des machettes qui se
demandaient pourquoi je faisais venir
des gens de l'ethnique laquelle il était
en conflit
visiblement meurtrier il a fallu
vraiment que je fasse preuve d'humilité
que je me taise sur tout mais vraiment
que je me taise vous montrer que j'avais
était juste un imbécile ce que j'avais
été et donc la tête d'humilité m'a sauvé
la vie autant que mon arrogance
peut-être indirects sans le vouloir je
pensais pas travaux dont je vous dis je
fais comme ça je fais locale
après tout bon choix au sud soudan c'est
pas facile je vais faire comme tout le
monde et puis toute façon ils verront
bien je suis pas dit si c'est pas un
problème
bah si c'est un problème mon arrogance
un peu indirects celle sur laquelle on
est tous susceptibles de tomber un jour
m'a fait faire cette erreur en même
temps j'ai pu le rattraper son stage je
ne serais pas en train de vous parler
actuellement
donc ça c'est une très bonne leçon
croyez moi donc du coup je me suis
imposé un régime d'auto discipline donc
je regarde toujours avant d'aller
quelque part les situations autant que
je peux le comprendre
et quand je ne sais pas j'ai c'est de
savoir où je ne sais pas pour me
renseigner
ensuite également quand on est sur place
quel que soit le pays où vous êtes votre
luxembourg comme au zimbabwe comme aux
îles caïmans ou comme je pense des
paradis fiscaux auteur donc il faut
vraiment pouvoir regarder où vous êtes
et quelles sont les situations la
situation dans la façon qu'elle évolue
c'est extrêmement important
planifiez également toutes vos
opérations
ce n'est pas parce que vous connaissez
bien pays où une zone il ne faut pas
planifié en détail vos opérations si
vous allez pour des raisons
professionnelles ou personnelles
on s'agite votre sécurité de votre
réussite commerciale et enfin il faut
vraiment garder lé enthousiasme et cet
enthousiasme là vous l'avez que si vous
êtes vous savez qui vous êtes et
pourquoi vous le faites
la clé de tout dans ces situations dans
la mondialisation c'est vous qui êtes
vous comment vous sentez vous comment
vous observez vous
vous faites qui vous voulez c'est vous
qui choisissez vous n'avez pas vous
faire imposer une identité par quelqu'un
d'autre
simplement quand vous aller quelque part
ça chez qui vous êtes et n'essayez pas
sous prétexte de devenir un gros bogue
mindset heures soit de vouloir adapter
une culture internationale qui vous
semble un petit peu caricatural le lot
lancé par les opérations de marketing de
grandes marques qui ont leur
justification mais qui n'est pas une
identité à adopter ou à l inverse
n'essayez pas de singer les cultures
locales si vous n'êtes pas du tout
adapté à cette culture là vous pouvez
tout à fait être acceptée dans une
culture qui n'est pas la vôtre en étant
vous même
il s'agit précisément de garder cette
distance en même temps ce respect c'est
essentiel alors ça c'est vraiment la
bonne nouvelle parce qu'en fait c'est
vous qui êtes au coeur du projet et
c'est sûr vous allez travailler et quoi
que vous fassiez vous allez vous
transformez à l'eau world merci beaucoup
à tous
[Applaudissements]